Hi, and welcome to our webcast today on
MBA student insights, women at the GSB.
My name is Toda Allouez, and I'm a first
year MBA student here at the GSB.
And today I'm joined by Rishi Lilly and
Val Young, who are both second years and
about to graduate.
We'll be talking about the student
experience here on campus.
And we're here to answer as many
questions as you might have.
To submit a question, just click on
the chat button at the top of your screen,
put in the question, and
click send to all the panelists.
So today we won't be talking about
anything related to admissions process,
or the application, or financial aid,
but people from the staff from the MBA
admissions office are here
to answer your questions.
You just type the question
into the chat box.
So let's start with some introductions.
Rishi and Val, please just tell
us a little bit about yourselves,
where you're from,
what you did before the GSB, and what
you're looking to do after graduation.
So-
>> Okay.
>> Yes Rishi you can go first, yeah.
>> I'm from Texas, born and raised, went
to University of Chicago for undergrad.
And I've spent four years in
Chicago doing executive search,
where I helped build additional
health practice and then came here.
And after school,
I'll be doing health tech.
>> Nice, thank you Rishi.
You want to go now, Val?
>> Sure.
Hi, I'm Val and
I am from New Hampshire originally.
Went to Bowdoin College in Brunswick,
Maine, I graduated in 2008.
Shortly thereafter, I moved to DC and
I spent about six years after
college before coming to
business school in politics.
Most recently I was in
the US Senate as a Chief of Staff.
Over the summer I worked at the Boston
Consulting Group in San Francisco, so
I'll be going back there after graduation.
I am interested in hopefully starting
something on my own at some point.
But spending a little time in consulting
before figuring out exactly
what my career path will be.
>> Thank you, Val.
So for me, again, I'm Toda Allouez.
I'm originally from Nigeria, and
I moved to the US about
seven years ago for college.
I went to Grinnell College in Iowa.
I double majored in computer science and
math,
and after that I worked as
a programmer at Goldman.
And then I did that for two years and
then came to the GSB last September.
After the GSB, I'm looking to remain in
technology, but do something more like
business development related
versus being a programmer or
software engineer on the tech side.
So let's get started with
questions from you guys.
So the first question is,
what's it like for women at Stanford,
both inside and outside the classroom?
>> You want to start?
>> Sure.
So I think I was pleasantly
surprised actually by
the sort of climate and
atmosphere for women here.
Our class, at least the class of 2016,
I'm not sure about the class for
the next year, was about a 60/40 split,
male to female,
and we had one of the highest percentages
of women at the GSB in history and so
that's been really nice.
I think that I have found a really
supportive group of male and
female friends here.
I definitely have found there are some
challenges coming into a place that, or
into an industry sort of as whole,
that has been historically male dominated,
and I think the GSB and the student
body are working through that and
sort of making progress as we go along.
And I'm happy to, obviously,
talk about that a bit more.
But, by and large,
I've actually found it much more inclusive
than I even anticipated coming in.
So, that's been really nice.
>> Okay, I think the thing that I'd add
onto that is I think starting our year,
we had this woman in management board, and
we started having formal members
who were men, women, join.
And we've had such a huge movement
of guys being involved in women.
And you just feel the support for
what used to be considered women's
issues as just issues that we all
talk about, and we all think about.
So there's definitely an open environment
to talk about what it means to be
a working mom, or to just like a working
parent rather than saying working mom.
And conversations like that,
which is really great and refreshing.
>> I actually was thinking
of one other thing that,
there's been some really great
formal stuff that Stanford has done.
I think informally, one of the things
that our classmates have really pushed is
diversifying some of those kind of side
conversations and group meetings and
things, particularly about
entrepreneurship and the start up world.
So I think we've found in the first
quarter, maybe first two quarters,
there were a lot of male groups
that were having informal and
formal conversations about
entrepreneurship and for
whatever reason women weren't
really as integrated into that.
I think women were having their
own separate conversations.
And I know a few classmates of ours made
a very concerted effort to start bridging
those two groups together, start thinking
about forming startup teams together.
And just kind of allowing that ecosystem
to cross over between male students and
female students.
And that has been something that I've
really appreciated going forward,
because I think those are the informal
networks and informal groups that start to
really make a big difference as
you move through your career.
>> Thank you, very good points.
So the next question is, how do you think
about timing to get your MBA in terms of
stepping out of your career for two years
and possibly starting a family some day?
>> I can start with that one.
I think getting our babies is a little
bit similar to having getting our MBA.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yes, exactly.
Getting our MBAs are little
similar to having a baby,
which is there may be no perfect time.
I think when one time when it is a really
good time is if you want to pivot, and
especially with regard to having a family.
I know a lot of families actually
have a baby while they're at the GSB,
maybe in the second year because that
seems like a good transition point.
So I guess my advice would be to
figure out first is this something you
really want?
Is this something that's
going to benefit your career?
And really think about how and why.
And then just after that, if you want it,
and if you want a family too,
just decide how you're going to
start piecing those things together.
It will never be perfect, the timing
will never be great, but you can do it.
>> Yeah, I would say as somebody that got
married in my first month of business
school, I would echo Rishi's thoughts
that the best laid plans always go awry.
So I had worked for
about six years before I came, I think.
Again to Rishi's point, it felt like
I had had some really awesome and
interesting accomplishments and
I was ready for some new challenges.
I think spending some time
thinking about when and
why you want to go is really important,
and I would sort of prioritize that.
The family stuff I think is tough for
women at any point in our careers,
at business school and
career trajectory thereafter.
And it's something that you and
your family and
your partner have to spend
some time thinking about.
I think that business school,
it'll fit into your life however
you need it to fit into your life.
If you're doing something like I'm doing,
which is kind of going into
a consulting firm where you're going to
have a couple of years where you may want
to not have kids at that point in time,
you may want to think about applying
a year or two earlier than you might.
I mean I'm 30, I'm probably slightly
on the older side of the GSB, or
average older, and it is something
we've thought about at one point,
when will we graduate,
when do we want to have a family?
So I think you make it work, but it's
something that you may want to at some
point kind of look to the future and start
backing out and saying, what are my goals?
Because I think your family goals
are as important as your career and
your education goals,
and you should just make sure that you're
thinking about those two things in tandem.
But I will say I think that the GSB is
a place where you can accommodate whatever
you choose and whatever needs
to be accommodated in your life.
So, don't let it be a hindrance.
But I would be thoughtful about it.
>> Thank you.
Next question is, are there any unique
opportunities for women in the MBA program
who are interested in pursuing
a career in the nonprofit sector?
>> That's a great question.
I did not pursue a career
in the nonprofit sector.
I think you might have that.
>> So I, when i came from the government
sector, which is different but
related, there is the Social
Innovation Career Services Center.
And I think that they have done a really
great job at building up a pretty robust,
both curriculum for folks that
are interested in nonprofit management,
sort of social innovation type fields,
and then they have a special
certificate that you can sort
of apply your credits towards.
And I think some really
great counselors and
advisors that have had quite
a distinguished career in those fields.
So I would say that I have kind of like,
dipped in and out of that a little bit.
I will be getting the certificate, but I
haven't probably utilized it to the degree
that some of our classmates, that are very
focused on nonprofit sector have.
That's at I think through 390s
which are our independent studies
through the CSI program and a few others.
There's a lot of opportunities to,
both within the curriculum and
outside the curriculum, design,
sort of study, and internships and
externships that allow you to get
involved in the nonprofit sectors.
You may have to be a little bit more
creative if they're not TAC, or they're
not San Francisco or Palo Alto affiliated
or located, but I think that there is
a lot of support here, and a number of
resources to help you be successful.
>> Yeah, thank you for that.
Just one thing I would like to
add is actually about the social
innovation trips.
>> Right.
>> Yeah, so
we have social innovation trips,
like just like every other study trip, but
this trips are just concentrated and
focused on social innovation I guess.
Yeah, so I know we have a bunch
to countries in Africa.
So we have one to Rwanda, Uganda,
maybe South Africa next year, and men,
women included,
they all go on these trips.
But these trips are a good example of how
you actually get to see the practical
applications of different products and
different innovative ideas
on people's lives, and how it actually
impacts people in Rwanda, Uganda or Kenya.
So that's a very, very unique opportunity
that you can explore if you're interested.
>> I don't know if there are any
women specific opportunities.
I do know that Alena won an award, right?
For social innovation.
And a scholarship for the GSB.
Also, Alena, I think and Ashley, right,
are starting their own nonprofit business.
So, there are women killing it-
>> [LAUGH]
>> At the GSB in the nonprofit sector.
>> And there is, I don't want to
misspeak because I don't know enough
about the specifics, but there is
a good amount of matching funds and
fund raising available for students that
over the summer want to do nonprofit work
if they're working at a 501C3, and also
obviously really great loan forgiveness
programs for those that go into
non-profit work after the GSP.
So those are two things that
I'm sure the admissions and
other staff members here could
talk about in more detail,
but there is quite a bit of financial
assistance that's provided as well.
>> Thank you.
So next question is how many of
the teachers and faculties are women?
Do you know a percentage?
>> I don't know the percentage,
I do know that some of our most
rockstar faculty members are women.
We have Maggie Neale for negotiation, I'm
actually doing independent study with her,
she's an incredible human being,
fantastic researcher.
We have Deb-
>> Grunfeld.
>> Yes exactly who with Amy Cutty
they did the work on Power Poses.
Those are two of my favorite professors.
Do you have?
>> Yeah I would say,
candidly,I think there are not
enough women faculty at the GSB.
My intuition tells me that,
that is probably true across
most of the business schools, certainly
most of the top business schools.
I think the GSB,
I know in their dean search and
in other communications that we've had
with the administration has really focused
on being particularly proactive
about increasing the numbers.
Especially as we get up
to the ten year level.
It's not, I think, where many of us
would like it to be in a perfect world.
But there are some really fantastic women
and I think they get a lot of support.
Anne Beyer, who was my first
year accounting professor,
won the Distinguished Teaching Award
from the students one year,
which is the student given award
to the best teacher at the GSB.
So, I don't have a number on percentage,
I think the percentage would be lower
than what most of us in this room
would like it to be, I think that's
a problem sort of across the board in
academia at this level and in this sector.
But it's something that we
talk about quite a bit,
the administration talks about quite a bit
and is trending in the right direction.
>> I do think women in
faculty are celebrated.
>> Yes definitely, yeah for sure.
I mean they're doing amazing things.
Some of them far outshine their male
colleagues and their male peers.
But I think in a perfect world,
there'd be more of them, and
I think there will be more
of them as time goes on.
>> Yeah.
Another faculty who's doing great work,
Carol Robin.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, Carol is amazing, right.
>> Exactly.
>> Amazing, yeah.
Well, thank you for
the very honest answer.
Next question.
What has been your favorite
experience at a GSB?
>> Mine is talk.
It's not a, I mean there's been
a million classroom things, and
a number of professors
that I'm super close with,
but my favorite thing about
the GSB is talk which we do,
the whole school and community is invited,
but mostly you do it with your class.
And it's kind of like Moth Radio Hour,
if anyone has ever heard of that.
It's basically 30 minutes or
so or an hour once a week
at night where everyone packs into
the MBA lounge and two people
give about a 30 minute talk of their life,
whatever they choose to focus on.
It's in those moments when
I'm at the GSB that I'm
just reminded of what a wonderful,
fantastic community we have.
And I feel most grateful for being there,
for getting to know these amazing
classmates, for hearing stories that
are so different and so, impactful.
And I think that that's something
that will stick with me for decades.
>> I want to add on to that and
then I'll share my favorite.
I think another really special thing
about talk is how people are able to
share things that they wouldn't usually
share in a different setting and
in creating that,
not only a safe space for that, but
also celebrating in a loving and
that bringing us all closer.
It's a really wonderful and
I think unique thing that we have here and
I'm sure other places have it as well,
but it's really special.
For my favorites,
I just love getting to know my classmates.
And that sounds silly, probably.
But as Val said, each person has
something incredible to share and
just warm, wonderful personalities.
There are very few people that I
wouldn't want to spend time with.
And so, any of the activities around that.
So we have small group dinners where first
year you are in a lottery system and
you get randomly assigned to, you can host
a small group generated with randomly
assigned people, so you get to know
different people in the class.
And that was one of my way to get
to know people whom I usually
wouldn't run into and
I really loved that experience and
with my really good friendships that
I came out of that So, we, thank you.
>> Colley, you can say C4C.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] [INAUDIBLE] She killed it,
being the head of C4C.
So C4C is Challenge for Charity,
no I actually really like C4C.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I really like it, I've been working so
hard to be on leadership for next year.
>> That's right.
>> Yeah.
>> And you
also like the CMC Committee, I know.
[LAUGH]
>> I like CMC.
[LAUGH] But anyway, C4C is a sporting
event that happens, hosted by Stanford
where west coast business schools are
invited to compete in different sports.
And Val was in charge of that,
this year was amazing.
I played basketball in college so
I brought my basketball skill.
>> Yeah.
>> And I helped Stanford,
>> I did not play basketball in college,
but I also brought my basketball skills.
>> Yes, and we killed it.
>> [LAUGH]
>> We killed it.
Yeah, it was really fun.
>> Yeah it's the culmination of a year
long fundraising and volunteering.
Competition among nine west
coast business schools, and
then we use the weekend to celebrate and
bring everyone together, so
there are 1300 students that come to
the GSB and it is a fantastic weekend.
>> It is really fun.
>> And with the dance competition,
and it is just amazing.
Okay, next question.
Has any particular club, including but
not limited to the women and
business club, had a tangible impact on
your career in terms of giving you new
opportunities that you might
not have known otherwise found?
>> So the clubs are great place to get new
opportunities, any of them, all of them.
And the way it works is a lot of jobs are
final thru and recruit management center,
but the each club has specific connections
with people in their industry, and so
sometimes jobs go directly to
the club leaders and funnel that way.
So definitely if you want to be in
healthcare join the healthcare club.
If you want to be in VC join the VC club.
It's a great way to do it.
In general, our network is incredible,
and you should use it.
And I'm just talking
about your classmates.
So even more so than the club, if there's
a company that you really want to work at,
forget if they have a job open, reaching
out to a classmate who either works
there or knows someone who work there,
and can give you an intro actually
really helps in terms of,
especially if you want to pivot and
your resume wouldn't scream I
am the person for this job.
It's a really good way to get a foot
in there and to advocate for yourself.
So I would strongly recommend doing that,
not only at the GSB but in life in
general, figuring out how you can use
your network to get you to new places.
>> Yeah, I think that's true.
I would say, I'm a member of the VC Club,
though I don't have immediate
plans to go into Venture Capital.
And there's been some amazing lunches and
dinners and opportunities to meet and
network with people that I would not
probably have otherwise had if I had not
been in the club or climbed onto
dinners that some of my friends host,
in the immediate term that's not something
that I'm going to probably capitalize on.
But long term these are some really cool,
fun,
interesting relationships and
interactions with people that I otherwise
would never have been able
to make the connection with.
So.
>> Thank you.
I think we have a lot of questions, so
we will try to answer as many as possible.
So the next one is, do you have any
plans to transition into a new industry.
A new role after your MBA and how do you
think that GSB has prepared you so far?
>> So
I have very strong opinions on this topic.
Yes and yes for me.
I am currently still interviewing, but
I said earlier I'm going to be working
health tech, either health tech or
tech and I'm in the process
of interviewing right now.
And how has the GSB prepared me for
the transition?
First, I'm just going to stop here and
say, if you come to the GSB or
anywhere and you know that you want to
pivot, do not take a breather on that.
You need to figure out
what you want to do.
What steps will get you there and
start mapping that out immediately.
And this is something we talk
a lot about MBA two year.
There's a lot of, do whatever you
want during the summer, [SOUND].
And that can be wonderful, and
you may still want to do that and
will not regret your decision but
you need to do it with full knowledge.
You can, if you want to make a huge pivot
using that summer to do it, is really key.
It's much easier to get a summer
internship and a new function and
a new role or either or or both,
than it is just to do it full time later.
So just think about that.
The next thing I'd say, what prepares you.
To both your classmates,
who can help you prepare for
interviews, which is extremely helpful.
Since they've done the jobs before,
they've probably interviewed people for
those roles before,
it's really helpful to leverage that.
And on the other side,
some classes really help you.
If you're going to go into a job where you
go and have to do financial modeling and
you've never done that before.
Take financial modeling.
You're going to go into operations,
take operations.
Make friends with the professor.
Get to know more about the subject.
It's really upon you though, to know what
you want to get out of the experience and
to be really focused about getting it.
>> Yeah, I would add,
I went into consulting,
which was totally different
from what I had done before.
I used both the consulting club,
the group management center alumni,
a ton of GSB alumni that are in
different firms, to both learn about,
sort of show my interest in,
and prepare for interviews.
I think that, in particular,
our classmates that offered to
do case interviews with me was some of the
most meaningful and helpful that I got.
So I think that has sort of facilitated,
in part, with career management center,
in part, separately through the consulting
club and just people giving their time.
So I think that that is true
across a number of industries, and
it's just my experience with consulting.
I would also say,
I've been working through Startup Grads on
a startup with another classmate of mine.
Startup Grad is just a really great class
if your interested in starting something
and that sort of design centered thinking
takes you through a couple of quarters
really going from zero to six as startup.
And that has been really fantastic
as far as just introducing me to
entrepreneurship, connecting
me with investors and
leaders in the field and other students
that are doing something similar.
And so that, as a class, I think,
has been an unbelievable crash course
in entrepreneurship which is something
that long-term I hope to get into.
And it's definitely been,
like kind of given me the training wheels
almost to go and do it on my own so.
>> Thank you.
The next question is, are there any
specific initiatives, whether in classes,
leadership coaching, or any of that,
that's helped prepare women students in
particular for a career in traditionally
male dominated industries?
>> Acting the power, right?
I mean [LAUGH], I-
>> Yeah
>> Yeah, that's a good, I mean, so
I think WIM focuses on
it quite a bit through
different programming and
conversations that they facilitate.
I think that there are some really cool
classes, including the one we were talking
about with Deb Greenfield, which is
called, Acting with Power, which is all
about understanding how you present,
how you take power, give away power.
I think some of the things that we think
about when you think about women not
speaking up in meetings, or
how you sit in a meeting,
or how to approach
a difficult conversation.
I think-
>> There's women in entrepreneurship.
>> Yeah.
That's been a great class actually.
Which is also Vogus.
I don't know that there are a ton
of initiatives focussed on women
getting into male dominated industries.
There are male dominated industries and if
you're a woman who wants to get into that,
all the support in the world to get you
there including male classmates who Were
in or will be in those industries,
professors who I know have helped
some of our female colleagues and
classmates get into those industries
such as private equity search.
[INAUDIBLE] So
I think Women In Entrepreneurship is a
great example though of a specific class.
So there's Professor Fern Mandelbaum
who's investing, angel investing,
venture capital a few other things.
She hosts a class specifically
around sort of encouraging women to
get into entrepreneurship
either by starting something or
getting into the investing side.
And brings in a ton of women in the valley
and also men in the valley that
are really supportive of getting more
women involved in those industries.
And that is sort of soft skills
like meeting these people,
hearing from other people that
have a similar world view to you.
And being able to picture
yourself in that role and
also some really tangible
conversations that we
had amongst us about what's holding women
back from being in those industries.
What would you look for, you know how
do we start to change the culture.
So that's a great example,
there is also a lot of programming around
women through the CMC and others
just about like public speaking and.
You can get one on one coaching and
things like that.
>> And negotiations.
>> Negotiations, yeah.
>> There's a lot of support,
yeah absolutely.
>> Thank you, next question.
Do you have any insights on
what the experience is like for
partners joining their girlfriends or
wives at Stanford?
Especially given the location of Stanford
and the living experience here on campus.
I have a fantastic GSP SO,
significant other,
husband who lives on campus with me so
I live in Escondido Village.
I have this awesome one bedroom which
is so below market rate in Palo Alto.
It's incredible.
If I could squat there for
the next ten years, I would stay.
And I think so my husband.
It is definitely different having a male,
significant other like a male SO
than what is more traditional
which is females SO's probably.
My husband loves Palo Alto,
which really helps.
He says it's like our country club
that he gets to come home to.
He works in the city, he has made a great
network of both other male SOs and
then some of my male classmates.
It definitely took a little bit of time
for him to get himself into the community.
He takes the CalTrain into San Francisco.
It's not a perfect commute,
but tons of people do it.
He had like a really good support network.
I think that the best thing for him which
has been so great, is he has been able to
tap into the GSB network for
his own career ideas and transition.
So he recently moved from energy
clean tech to health tech,
and really utilized the GSP network for
that.
Both the SO community and the student
community, and I think that what has been
the nicest thing about this is my GSP
network has become his GSP network, and
we get kind of double the network
which is really nice, so.
>> I'm going to give
a slightly different take.
I also have a significant other.
He's long distance,
lives in Chicago, my fiance,
and so, I will say it's hard.
>> Yeah, it's definitely hard.
>> It's hard.
Like you go from maybe living together,
spending a lot of your time together.
Even if you're working really hard to
being thrown into a completely different
environment where a lot of your
time is spent meeting new people,
doing new GSB things and it's really.
It can be really hard to integrate both of
you to live in that world and I just want
to acknowledge it's hard because I think
it would be hard at any business school.
I'm actually sure it is
just given the experience.
But just be aware of that and
kind of talk about it and
talk about how you're
going to work with that.
It's just a difference in lifestyle,
a difference in the time that you
can allocate to your relationship.
It also, I will say something.
In some ways it's been easier
because he's long distance.
So he doesn't have to hang
out with GSPers all the time,
he has his own group of friends.
And in some ways it's harder, because at
this point, Val's husband has friends
inside and outside of the class,
>> Mm-hm.
>> Whom he also loves,
who've become part of his family,
and that happens around second year.
So Anschel never quite got there, right?
But he never had the roughness of
me not being at home all the time,
cause we were just apart.
>> Yeah,
I mean it's definitely a challenge,
you have to spend a lot of time thinking
about how you allocate your time.
I think the one thing you'll
realize at business school is
that time is the precious resource.
And so when you have a relationship,
you need to figure out how you fit that in
with all the other stuff
that you have going on.
But lots of people are doing it,
there's lots of people talking about it.
>> We also write it.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Even.
>> Yes so.
Unfortunately we're almost out of time and
we still have many questions but
just to summarize this, [INAUDIBLE] and
Val what would be your final pieces
of advice before you graduate,
what advice do you have?
For people watching today and,
I guess, for
me too, since I'm going to
be a second year next year.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I think the one thing
that I've gotten out of the GSB, and I
would say it starts with the application,
is this idea of authenticity,
which I find my dean talks about.
But, the GSB focuses a lot on being
introspective and being really true to who
you are and aligning your both
professional and personal values and
desires to that.
And it starts with the application,
what matters most to you?
Really think about that question.
I did a lot of introspective research when
I did my essay and that really helped me
figure out what I really wanted out of the
GSB, out of life, out of my personal life.
And help me pave a part forward,
and I would say do the same, for
you to do the same, because that journey
will just continue when you're here.
>> Yeah, I think, I would echo
a lot of what Ritchie said, and
in addition, what made me choose
the GSB was the community,
I think this is the best place
in the world, it's the most.
>> Fantastic group of people and
supportive group of people.
In your application, and when you get
here, remember that you are an important
part of that community because of
the unique things that you bring.
I think I spent the first you
know quarter or half year even.
Worrying that I wasn't
business school enough or
that my background in government
wasn't valuable enough.
And as I'm leaving and reflecting I'm
realizing that I had so much to offer.
I have so much to offer that my
classmates have a lot to learn from me.
And I have a lot to learn from them.
And so I would say come in
with the confidence and
apply with the confidence that you will
bring so much to the community yourself.
And also remember that you have so much
to learn from the people that are here.
And I think that when you can
embrace that give and take,
you'll be in a place to really capitalize
on all that the GSB has to offer.
I agree with that.
>> I echo everything she and Bao said.
I'll just add something that I heard
from someone, which blew my mind.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So applying to the GSB, most people see
it as a marketing exercise, so marketing
themselves and trying to showcase all
the great things you guys have done,
which I'm sure are great things.
But people see it more as marketing.
But rather you should
see it as accounting.
Where you're trying to
take stock of yourself.
So you're trying to take
stock of your strengths and
areas that you want to improve on.
So yeah you're trying to
display those strengths but
you also want to be aware of what you
want to get out of the experience
like those parts of your life that you
want to change or you want to improve.
So even though you want
to get into the GSB,
you want to make sure it's a good
match both for you and for the GSB.
And just like Risha and Val said,
you want to come through authentic in
your essay and in your application.
Just be yourself,
let your personality shine and
just so we want to get to know you.
>> Do I count in?
Yeah.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Do I count in am I kidding?
>> Okay, yeah.
>> So thank you both for joining us today
>> Of course.
>> You too.
>> Sharing all this wisdom.
>> Thank you for joining us.
[LAUGH]
>> Yeah, thank you very much for
joining us.
You can learn more about the MBA
program on the GSP website,
and the application for
the class after for
the class that's in the fall of
2017 will be available in June.
And if you have any questions
about the MBA program,
you can submit them in the chat books
as you've been submitting them.
And the staff from
the MBA admissions office
will be able to answer your question
within the next 15 minutes.
Thank you very much.
Again and have a wonderful day.
Bye.
>> Bye.